Adam the the fighting has pretty much
died down now for the evening the pesh
MERGA don't necessarily fight very much
at night but they were able to
accomplish all of their planned
objectives for today they've established
a blocking position to the east of the
city of Sinjar in a second blocking
position about four kilometers to the
west of Sinjar coalition airpower is
played a significant part in this there
were over 30 airstrikes conducted
beginning about midnight last night we
estimate those airstrikes have probably
killed roughly 70 is fighters during the
course of this battle and will continue
to apply pressure as the night goes on
from the air and then we'll restart the
offensive in the morning and what would
be the role I mean work going to detail
off Special Forces whether british or
american well the primary role of
coalition forces here is to advise pesh
MERGA commanders they locate themselves
with the pêche commanders and senior
leadership back from the front lines
where there isn't an opportunity for
them to receive any direct fire we do
have a small number of American advisors
atop Mount Sinjar helping those pêche
fighters develop targets identify strike
zones that type of activity and how
united is the Kurdish force I asked
because the New York Times is reporting
that there is a significant number of
fighters loyal to the PKK rather than to
the Peshmerga and that they're operating
independently well in what we've seen so
far is it is a unified front these pesh
MERGA and the Kurds in general are very
much right now focused on liberating
Sinjar they've got a very common enemy
named is and they are determined to see
Sinjar and ruu liaising at all with
forces loyal to the PKK we do not we
weally our liaison is really primarily
through the government of Iraq and then
of course through the Kurdish regional
now you're speaking to us from Iraq
course we're mosel is located just how
strategically significant is this battle
this is a very significant battle for
two reasons reason one which you've
spoken about is that it cuts that major
line of communication between Rocca and
Mosul we believe this will begin to
significantly degrade isil's ability is
his ability to shuttle men and material
between their two primary hubs in raka
and in Mosul it won't cut it off
completely there's still ratlines and
smuggling routes in the desert to the
south but we believe this will have a
significant impact and then there is the
symbolic nature of this fight this is
the largest operation that the Peshmerga
have undertaken thus far has gone very
cleanly we're very pleased with the way
the Peshmerga have organized themselves
and have fought and it's really the next
step in the eventual operation for mosel
itself we began shaping fires almost a
year ago as we as we strike leaders in
Mosul as we do things to interdict the
lines of communication into Mosul so
this is a significant battle and how
difficult is it for you that within the
coalition you've obviously got
considerable antagonism between the
Kurds and the Turks who are also
important in this battle well this is
this is really something for the
diplomats to work on thus far we've
managed to to take everyone's concerns
into account and continue to prosecute
this battle against is and if you had to
estimate how long are you estimating for
this operation to take our initial
planning shows that it will probably be
2 to 4 days before the pêche can seize
Sinjar and then it will probably take
them another week to be able to back
clear and reduce all of those booby
traps obstacles mines and IEDs that that
ISIL has shown throughout the city